the Joe Rogan experience yeah exactly
well what about androgyny and rose I was
yeah I was scared for Rose was a really
bad landing landing on her neck like
that was terrifying that's what scared
me just because we were in Brazil too
and that crowd was crazy mm-hmm and
everybody shot up and started screaming
and Rose was just like laid out on the
campus and I kind of was just like
wanting her corner to be in there with
her cuz she was just all alone about
herself right you know and I was worried
that she wasn't gonna get up I was like
cake he was like wait to cheer until I
see she's okay cuz that can paralyze
someone 100% yeah if you look at the
impact have you seen the photograph of
the landing itself I mean it's it's one
of the worst ways you could ever land
she's essentially headfirst with the
neck sideways and flattened yeah space
yeah it's like someone was cranking on
her neck it's horrible yeah that was a
bad landing I mean the whole thing was
bad she's going for the Kimura Jessica
picks her up she doesn't lace a leg and
she holds on the Kimura which you just
can't do you just can't do you got to
let it go you know but she she's she's
held on to things before and you know
and caught arm bars and triangles and
it's one of those things you know you
make mistake so cuz I know people were
talking about it being illegal to slam
somebody like that she didn't do it on
purpose she just tried to slam her I
mean she's just trying to take lifts her
up and dump her down what did she think
of her loss to on drugs that was crazy
I feel like styles make fights hmm and
it was the perfect fight for and Wragge
to showcase her knockout power because
KK is a pressure fighter and she
instinctively will go forward and throw
when she is in danger and sometimes it
works and sometimes it doesn't you know
yeah and she throws hard obviously she
put you wanna you know she buckled you
on a couple times she's dangerous she's
she won against Rose yeah you know so
but yeah I think styles make fights and
that's that's what happened with her in
that situation what do you think
and Raj is unusually strong yeah like
freakish you know like you see when she
grabs ahold of people and then dumps him
on their ass like she's she's freakishly
powerful to be able to like hit that
single and elevate Rose that way and
drop her on her head when you think
about how strong you have to be to do
that it's beautiful yeah beautiful to
watch she's a beast
great technique as well no no doubt
about it but man horsepower and I figure
I honestly I I gave it to rose to win
the fight it only takes a split second
though to lose your focus and to get
picked up and slams it down like that
and then the fights over for the
division that's actually probably good
because it's exciting because it mixes
things up a bit you have Johanna who is
the dominant champion for so long Rose
comes along she beats her and then
Jessica dumps rose in her head beats her
in a fight that she was losing I mean
it's like it's a hotbed of talent it's a
115-pound women's division is amazing
right yeah it really is yeah yeah and so
that's what I'm letting that's exactly
what I want and in the meantime we just
we just get better beautiful weight we
train and we get better I feel like
what's gonna beat on judges um I mean
Rose had Rose was doing exactly what she
was doing I think that rules
actually kind of got a bit just just a
little bit complacent and and like she's
even said it herself it was a moment of
of laziness elapsed yeah well it's easy
to mean so hard after the fact to try to
figure out what went wrong and why it
went wrong what was going on in her head
but clearly it was not lacing up the
legs when she's attacking the Kimora she
was elevated and dumped and and and I'm
sure for a lot of her camp she's she was
able to do that with with her teammates
and improv pop off good submissions you
know but in the moment of a fight for a
championship belt in your hometown
against a person that's bread and butter
is
a piledrive you know it it's just like
stacks up against you well good luck
trying to find someone as strong as Val
as her outside of me Valentino who she
does train with I mean but Jessica and
ROG is probably one of the strongest
women in 150 pound division she's so
damn strong so good luck trying to find
someone to replicate that and try it and
you don't train that you don't judge
train the piledriver like that's
dangerous yeah that's one of the things
that she does train Valentina though
who's one of the strongest women at 125
Valentina's a tank that's a very strong
woman but her style is different to show
that she's a counter fighter and she
picks and chooses when she wants to go
and she hold you down drugged her yeah
like her takedowns
are not on joshs takedowns right you
know so I don't know it is one of the
things that's so exciting about the
sport is that there are so many
different ways to approach it
there's so many different ways here's
your way karate style there's you Lana's
way Muay Thai you know there's something
this jessica's way bulldog get a hold
you take her down and you know in a lot
of ways you want to also showed how to
beat Jessica I just I feel the
difference with your Manan Rose is that
Rose because this is just my opinion
because Rose has it has shown to have
more variety in her in her toolbox she's
really good grappling and this and that
that I don't think she's as she's not
hesitant to go to the ground I feel like
if if the situation allowed it she would
go to the ground and even get a
submission on and Wragge
whereas with joanna she knows what she
has to do to win and she'll be stubborn
in that sense and do that for five
minutes for five rounds consistently you
know I mean mm-hmm and I feel like with
Rose she's she will she'll take risks
and and a lot of times it does work for
her you know and sometimes it just
doesn't
yeah and that was just one of those
times yeah just it's interesting to see
her talk about
writing in period that she doesn't know
if she has that in her anymore just to
be mean to a person to hurt a person I
thought that was really interesting
she's yeah I love how honest she is but
I also feel like a big part of her
getting the belt was to know that she
could you know to know that she could
take down you wanna the invincible you
know and then she did that and then it
was like alright well now I know that I
can and it's kind of like well I've
already I've already accomplished what I
wanted to accomplish I don't know maybe
that's just me thinking out loud of what
maybe she might be going through what
might be going on in her mind
you know let's say if you fought and Raj
and you beat her and you become a
champion would that take a significant
amount of motivation away from you or
would you have more motivation to defend
it so we talked about this too because
that's been such a huge goal of mine is
to be the champ
um and I want to say two fights ago we
started implementing visualizations of
me being the champ and defending about
and how that would look like you know
and this is with your psychologist hmm
with my sports psychologist and yeah so
that that makes the mountain higher mmm
you know it's like it's not the end game
once you get the belt and coach Jackson
would say that all the time it's easy to
become the champ it's harder to stay the
champ
[Applause]